dann doch eine große Koalition und was
steht noch an die FDP will die
Niederlagenserie der letzten Wahlen
beenden und mindestens mal den
Wiedereinzug ins Parlament schaffen und
dann gibt es dann noch die BIW BÜRGER IN
WUT die den Protest einsammeln will mit
guten Chancen denn die AFD darf wegen
Formfehler nicht antreten wer seine
Ziele erreicht wissen wir schon besser
mit der Prognose gleich um 6 so ist es
18 Uhr die magische Zeit immer pünktlich
die Prognose der Forschungsgruppe Wahlen
in dieser Wahlsendung werfen wir aber
auch einen Blick auf die andere Wahl des
Tages die über Deutschland hinaus für
Europa von größter Bedeutung ist in der
Türkei haben die Wahllokale bereits
geschlossen was aber anders als bei uns
nicht bedeutet dass es sofort relevante
Prognosen gäbe
ist unser Korrespondent in der Türkei
und uns aus Ankara zugeschaltet ja Jörg
der Begriff Schicksalswahl der wird oft
ziemlich leichtfertig verwendet hier
trifft er zu jedenfalls auf die Frage ob
die Türken Präsident Erdogan nach 20
Jahren abwählen oder es weiter oder er
sich weiter in der Macht halten kann wie
läuft der Wahlabend ab hier irgendwann
gibt es belastbare Trends
also was ich jetzt hier schon mal sagen
kann ist dass die obere oberste
Wahlbehörde ihre ihre Deadline für die
Verkündung der ersten Zahlen drastisch
verkürzt hat die liegt normalerweise bei
20 Uhr deutscher Zeit und die wurde
jetzt nach vorne geschoben das heißt
seit ungefähr einer Viertelstunde dürfen
die Fernsehsender die ersten Zahlen
veröffentlichen die ersten ausgezählten
Wahlkreise es sind bisher ungefähr 11%
der Stimmen ausgezählt das ist das was
wir hier sehen können und demnach liegt
im Moment jedenfalls Präsident Erdogan
mit ungefähr 58% in Front und sein
Herausforderer Kemal kilica UNO liegt
bei 35 % diese Zahl die ich hier jetzt
gerade genannt habe die ist natürlich
überhaupt noch nicht belastbar weil das
sind kleinere Wahlkreise die da sehr
schnell ausgezählt werden konnten und
insofern muss man davon ausgehen dass
ich diese Zahlen im Laufe des Abends
auch noch stark verändern können
mir im Vorfeld immer berichtet das ist
ein knapper Wahlausgang wird dass die
ersten Zahlen deuten zwar nicht darauf
hin aber wir müssen jetzt wirklich den
Abend mal abwarten der Wahlgang selbst
so weit wir das selbst auch beobachten
konnten hier in Ankara der war relativ
friedlich der war relativ geordnet auch
gut organisiert natürlich gab es
einzelne Berichte über Unstimmigkeiten
jetzt muss man mal sehen in welchem
Ausmaß die dann auch tatsächlich
gemeldet werden die Polizei hat sich
jedenfalls vorbereitet auf Ausschreitung
vor allem gibt es hier große
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen um die oberste
Wahlbehörde hier in Anker herum denn
dort werden dann diese Einsprüche
verhandelt und entschieden und auch das
Wahlergebnis dann verkündet aber bis
dahin ist es noch Zeit das wird erst
morgen nachmittag passieren es wird
jedenfalls entspannender Abend mit
interessanten ersten Zahlen in der Tat
danke schön ja für diese ersten Trends
und bitte melde dich sobald neue Zahlen
vorhanden sind wir widmen uns jetzt
zunächst den Bremer Verhältnissen wie
wirkt es sich aus wenn mehr als 60% der
Wahlberechtigung finden dass ihr Land
schlecht auf die Zukunft vorbereitet
seid zu den Sorgen der Menschen und den
Themen des Wahlkampf matthiaskovica
das kleinste der 16 der zwei
städte-staat im Nordwesten Bremen und
Bremerhaven nach Einwohnern nicht mal
halb so groß wie München
ein Stück Deutschland mit exklusiver
Story
und ganz eigenem stolz mein Mann sagt
immer Bremen ist ein Dorf mit
Straßenbahn
historische Hansestadt zwischen
Bilderbuch und Realität mit chronisch
wenig Kohle den Bremern wichtig bei
dieser Wahl schlauere Lösungen für den
Verkehr
man müsste auch ein bisschen noch die
Autofahrer mit einbeziehen dass sie
nicht komplett außen vor sind ich denke
das ist Bereiche geben muss in den Autos
einfach komplett kann sogar mehr haben
sollten
Bremens Dauerproblem die Bildung jetzt
noch akuter weil viele Lehrer fehlen
sehr viel sogar und das ist halt richtig
[Musik]
trotzdem die Klausuren schreiben müssen
Angst Träume rings um den Hauptbahnhof
Bremen kämpft seit Jahrzehnten gegen die
Drogenkriminalität
gerade so als junge Frau
Bremerhaven erfindet sich neu am Wasser
alles ganz schick in der zweiten Reihe
aber ist der Lack ab in der einst
stolzen Werften statt
[Musik]
was hat Bremerhaven denn Bremen hat
alles also man sagt ja oft über die
Stadt laufen und wir bleiben auf jeden
Fall
so erkennt man im kleinsten das große
denn in Bremen spiegeln sich viele
Probleme der gesamten Republik
ja so ist es wohl und ich habe bei mir
kein niklasche ist der Leiter des
zdf-landesstudios in Bremen hat
natürlich den Wahlkampf sehr intensiv
beobachtet die SPD regiert Bremen seit
mehr als 70 Jahren jetzt mit grün und
rot gab es denn im Wahlkampf sowas wie
eine Wechselstimmung ja eher nicht und
das LAG vornehmlich daran dass Andreas
bovenschulte alles überlagert hat im
positiven Sinne für die SPD die SPD hat
eigentlich seit langem nicht mehr so ein
Landesvater gehabt der populär ist über
die Partei Grenzen hinweg wenn man mal
manches Wahlplakat betrachtet hat dann
war da nur eine Aussage Andreas bovente
und ich hatte Gelegenheit einige
Ereignisse mit ihm zu begleiten und da
waren einige Wähler die sagten
normalerweise will ich grün oder CDU
diesmal überlege ich Andreas
bogenschulte zu wählen Fang immer hat
seine Rolle auch gut gespielt das
Herausforderer aber er konnte ihm diese
Wechselstimmung nicht erzeugen weil
dieser populäre Mann an der Spitze der
SPD war der dadurch auch einige Probleme
kaschiert hat wir haben es eben in den
Beitrag gesehen Bildung ein Dauerbrenner
aber auch innere Sicherheit um den
Bahnhof herum fühlen sich die Leute
nicht sicher das ist uns immer wieder
aufgefallen das muss geändert werden wir
immer bald regiert und dann die
Verkehrspolitik die Grünen haben sehr
ambitionierte Pläne und Ziele sie wollen
eine autofreie Innenstadt und Maike
Schäfer hat dadurch ein bisschen sich
den Unmut der Autofahrer zugezogen die
oft im Stau standen und vielleicht
zahlen die Grünen deswegen die Zeche ja
wohl Mike Schäfer eigentlich auch eine
sehr veritable Spitzenkandidatin war
danke für diese Eindrücke aus dem
Wahlkampf danke und wir sind in unserer
Wahlsendung natürlich wie immer bei den
Parteien vertreten heute Abend und
beginnen bei den
koregierungsparteien Grünen und Linken
die Linke ist in den Ländern inzwischen
seit Jahren auf der Verlierer Straße
zuletzt verlor sie in Berlin und flog
dort aus der Regierung aus Bremen soll
nun ein hoffnungssignal kommen vor allem
wollen die Linken ja weiter mit regieren
was rechnen sie sich aus
man ist hier relativ zuversichtlich es
ist hier auch schon ordentlich voll die
Linkspartei trifft sich bei einer Bremer
Brauerei und das passt vielleicht auch
ganz gut denn mit Bierzapfen kennt sich
die Spitzenkandidatin der Linkspartei
bestens aus sie selbst war mal
Kneipenbesitzerin mittlerweile hatte
sich aber als pragmatische
Wirtschaftssituation Bremen einen Namen
gemacht und kommt was viele kommen für
möglich gehalten haben auch bei vielen
Unternehmen gut an wenn Sie selbst würde
den Job natürlich gerne behalten die
Linkspartei hofft ja auch so ein
zweistelliges knappes Ergebnis und
natürlich auf eine Fortsetzung von rot
grün rot auch wenn Rückenwind der
Bundespartei wie Kristina Fuchs selbst
sagt anders aussieht
danke schön Eva dann gehen wir zu den
Grünen die beim letzten Mal mehr als 17
% erreichten und dafür ein super
Ministerium erhielten Klimaschutz Umwelt
Verkehr Wohnungsbau jetzt vier Jahre
später haben müssen die Grünen mit
kräftigen Verlusten rechnen mehr als
jeder andere Partei in der Kirchheim bis
die Stimmung
die Stimmung die ist gut noch sagen Sie
hier im Schlachthof in Bremen die
Erwartungen der Partei an sich selbst
die waren ja lange sehr sehr hoch mehr
als 17 Prozent nach der letzten Wahl und
eigentlich sollten es heute Abend gern
noch mehr werden in die Umfrage lag die
Partei zuletzt allerdings deutlich
darunter aber es wird heute nicht um
jeden einzelnen Prozentpunkt gehen
sondern auch und die gemeinsame Arbeit
in der Regierung und da lief es nicht
immer optimal für die Spitzenkandidatin
Michael Schäfer hinzu kommt noch dass
die Grünen nach der letzten Wahl als
Königsmacher der SPD in den
Koalitionsvertrag mehr oder weniger
hinein diktieren konnten und das hat
nicht eingefallen immerhin Bürgermeister
bobenschulte lobte zuletzt die gute
Zusammenarbeit zwischen den Parteien
danke schön Linda ja die Grünen waren es
die vor vier Jahren dem Wahl Verlierer
SPD die Regierungsmacht sicherten als
die Sozialdemokraten wir uns ja schon
gehört zum ersten Mal nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg nicht mehr stärkste Kraft an
der Weser geworden waren eine
historische Niederlage die bogenschulte
jetzt wieder gut machen will Matthias
Kubitza mit einem Blick auf das Rennen
der Parteien und ihrer Spitzen Leute im
Lande Bremen
vor vier Jahren die CDU stärkste Kraft
Sensation an der Weser doch Bremen blieb
links mit Rot-Grün-Rot
Andreas bovenschulte will Bürgermeister
bleiben dank üppig im Amtsbonus liegt
die SPD knapp vorn
die jetzige Koalition hat eine gute
Arbeit gemacht aber wir gehen bewusst
wie jede andere Parteien in Bremen auch
nicht mit einer festen Koalitionsaussage
in die Wahl für die CDU kämpft diesmal
Frank Imhoff Landwirt und Präsident der
Bürgerschaft für das Ende der SPD
dauerregentschaft
jede Serie bricht irgendwann und jetzt
ist die Zeit gerade reif das merkt man
in der Stimmung der Bevölkerung und
deswegen wird das auch klappen die
Grünen zuletzt in der Defensive und
heute wohl schlechter als beim letzten
Mal
gut zusammengearbeitet Hand in Hand
wieder zusammengearbeitet und haben
trotz Pandemie trotz Energiekrise als
Rot-Grün roter Senat auch viel bewegt
auch die Linke hofft die Macht nicht zu
verlieren
ja wir wollen ja in der jetzigen
Regierungskonstellation weiterarbeiten
das hat auch damit was zu tun damit dass
wir ein paar Sachen sehr erfolgreich auf
den Weg gebracht haben die FDP
traditionell schwach in Bremen trotzdem
mit Ansprüchen
natürlich ist unser Ziel dass wir auch
Regierungsverantwortung übernehmen aber
das kann ja nicht dazu führen dass man
sämtliche eigenen inhaltlichen Punkte
über Bord wirft die Bürger in Wut
vielleicht zweistellig weil die AFD
nicht antreten darf wie eine
konservative Politik wird unabhängig
davon was er vorher gewählt hat ob CDU
oder AFD hat mit uns eine echte
Alternative die Frage des Abends aber im
Hof oder bodenschulte schwarz oder rot
wer wird diesmal vorne liegen und für
welches Bündnis wird es reichen
die Frage und die vertiefen wir jetzt
das Rennen an der Spitze SPD gegen CDU
im Wahlkampf waren sie eher sanft
miteinander und eine große Koalition hat
durchaus ja auch eine Tradition in
Bremen wenn es um den gewünschten
Ministerpräsident Präsidenten geht ist
das Votum der Wähler Matthias allerdings
ziemlich klar ja so sieht's aus andreas
bovenschulter hat sich etabliert und
geht mit einem kräftigen Amtsbonus ins
Rennen das sehen wir hier 60% der
Wählerinnen und Wähler in Bremen wollen
dass der Regierungschef bleibt nur 23%
wünschen sich an Wechsel hin zu Frank
immer auf von der CDU der Vorsprung für
den SPD-Kandidaten ist also wesentlich
größer als vor vier Jahren
berufenschulte macht seine Sache gut das
Finden mehr als Dreiviertel der
Befragten und wir sehen hier dass die
Anhänger aller Parteien diese positive
Bewertung mehrheitlich teilen die
Beliebtheit des Regierungschefs ist also
ein Faktor hier bei der Wahl in Bremen
danke schön Matthias dann schauen wir zu
den wahlreportern zu gehen zu SPD und
CDU und beginnen bei der den Wahlamt bei
der CDU beobachtet als die Formfragen
sagen zwei voraus rechnet man sich
dennoch die Führung aus wie vor vier
Jahren oder setzt die CDU jetzt gleich
auf Platz
nein das sicher nicht wir sind gar nicht
weit entfernt von euch hier einmal quer
rüber mit den Domshof in der Markthalle
und hier überall am Rand steht Hoden
ständig und es gilt in gewisser Weise
auch für den Spitzenkandidaten Frank
immer auf der immer Wert darauf gelegt
hat als Milchbauer sehr bodenständig zu
sein und sehr bürgernah zu sein aber
ganz scheint die CDU nicht darauf
vertrauen zu wollen man hat ihm eine
junge Frau an die Seite gestellt 27 von
der klimaunion und das soll ganz sicher
dass Signal aussenden wir können auch
grün zwei Ziele sind formuliert zum
einen wenn es irgendwie doch wieder
stärkste Kraft zu werden und zweitens
weil man hat das beim letzten Mal
gesehen dass allein reicht nicht man
muss Partner gewinnen schon während des
Wahlkampf war man sehr hanseatisch
höflich das wird auch nach 18 Uhr gelten
wenn man sich hier ins Spiel bringen
will als möglicher koalitionskandidat
als möglicher Regierungspartner wenn
dann hier der Markt der Möglichkeiten
eröffnet wird
danke schön Ralf ja und dann noch zur
SPD die heute den Sieg einfahren und
natürlich weiter die Regierung stellen
will Christina von Ungarn Sternberg wie
groß ist die Zuversicht dass das auch
gelingt
mit Tina die Zuversicht ist groß auch
wir sind bei euch direkt um die Ecke in
einer Kneipe hier in der Bremer
Innenstadt in der normalerweise relativ
viel Alkohol getrunken wird und man muss
sagen dass die SPD sich in Bremen an
drei Sachen gewöhnt hat die eine ist
hier regieren große Männer Henning
Scherf wir erinnern uns zwei Meter
Vierter der jetzige Spitzenkandidat um
die zwei Meter das zweite ist man
regiert lange als Bremer Bürgermeister
ist man auch mal so 10 oder 20 Jahre im
Amt und das dritte ist man regiert
überhaupt ihr habt gesagt seit 1945 ist
Bremen
SPD regiert und man hofft dass das heute
abend auch so bleibt danke schön
Christina bis später ja und zurück im
waldstudio wir haben noch anderthalb
Minuten bis zu 18 Uhr Prognose wenn sie
was hören sind das möglicherweise hier
die Glocken das 18 Uhr läuft beim Dom
also das ist unsere tödliche Kulisse
sozusagen für den heutigen Abend
Professor Karl Rudolf Karte ist wie
immer bei uns ja guten Abend
professor-karte Bremen das kleinste
Bundesland eher schon eine
Bürgermeisterwahl könnte man sagen hält
diese Wahl trotzdem Botschaften bereit
auch über Bremen hinaus für Berlin auf
jeden Fall es sind bundesbürgermeister
Themen die hier ausprobiert werden im
Sinne der Mobilisierung wie kommen
Themen an es geht immer bei Wahlen um
machtprofilter sie Vermessung der
Berliner Republik verfolgt hier und vor
allem wie ab morgen die Koalition in
Berlin Zusammenarbeit mehr zusammen oder
weniger zusammen das werden wir gleich
sehen vielleicht noch ein kurzer Blick
auf die BIW die Bürger in Wut die sind
eigentlich vermutlich erwartet man
Profiteure dass die AFD hier nicht
ordentliche Listen aufgestellt hat ja
Profiteure der Angst im Prinzip Protest
drückt man dadurch aus dass man zu Hause
bleibt nicht wählt oder solche Parteien
wählt insofern ist das klassische
unmutsaufsaugerei und das werden wir
vermutlich auch erleben vielen
später natürlich weiter und schauen
jetzt auf die Uhr wir haben noch 20
Sekunden bis zur Prognose der
Forschungsgruppe Wahlen wer wird an der
Spitze sein beim letzten Mal war es die
CDU jetzt will die SPD das wieder gut
machen und will hier weiterregieren mit
der Regierung von Rot-Grün-Rot oder
kommt es anders wir werden es sehen in
fünf Sekunden drei zwei eins
die Prognose der Forschungsgruppe Wahlen
für das Land Bremen CDU 24,5 leichte
Verluste SPD 30 deutliche Gewinne grüne
zwölf deutliche Verluste linke 11
ähnlich wie beim letzten Mal FDP 5 mit
leichten Verlusten und wirklich unklar
ob Sie über diese fünf Prozent Hürde am
Ende kommt
10,5 sehr deutliche Gewinne andere
sieben so dass die Prognose und was
bedeutet das jetzt für diese Verteilung
und für diese Koalition Matthias genau
das schauen wir uns jetzt an die
Sitzverteilung in der Bremischen
Bürgerschaft 87 Sitze insgesamt 72 aus
Bremen 15 aus Bremerhaven und wir
schauen mal wie sich das nach der
Prognose 18 Uhr auf die Parteien
verteilen würde die CDU käme auf 23
Sitze die SPD auf 28 grüne 11 linke 10
die FDP 5 sehr knapp an der 5% Grenze es
zählt in den beiden Wahlbezirken Bremen
und Bremerhaven jeweils eine 5% Grenze
derzeit ist die FDP in beiden drüber die
BMW BÜRGER IN WUT bei 10%. was ist das
fürs Regieren hier in Bremen wir sehen
hier die amtierender Regierung SPD Grüne
und Linke die 44 Sitze Linie markiert
die absolute Mehrheit und das sehen wir
hier schaffen die locker SPD und CDU
eine hier in der Tat noch recht große
Koalition käme auf 51 Sitze noch
deutlicher drüber und wenn dann die FDP
drin wäre dann ginge auch eine Ampel
ganz knapp mit eben diesen 44 sitzen die
man mindestens bräuchte
vielen Dank heißt auch der SPD
Bürgermeister Andreas Bovenden Schulter
hat die Wahl er kann auf deutliche
Gewinne verweisen und schafft auch das
was beim letzten mal schiefgehen für die
SPD nämlich wieder stärkste Kraft zu
sein und deshalb gehen wir jetzt direkt
zur SPD und nehmen da noch mal die
Stimmung auf Christina von unseren
Sternberg ja das hat Freude bereitet
vermutlich
das hat große Freude bereitet Bettina
und zwar von Anfang an der Jubel brach
schon aus als man die CDU zahlen hier
gesehen hat und er wurde dann noch
größer als man die eigenen Zahlen
gesehen hat 30 Prozent ein großer
Abstand zur CDU da war hier große Jubel
und so ist man hier in Feierlaune bei
der SPD es hat sich ausgezahlt auf bovi
zu setzen wie Sie ihn hier nennen oh wie
Power Bowie rockt das war das Motto
dieses Wahlkampfs und man sagt hier
Bremen ist so viel besser man hat Corona
besser gemeistert als andere
Bundesländer eine Impfquote von über 90%
Wirtschaftswachstum ist besser als in
anderen Bundesländern im letzten Jahr
nach Corona also man sagt wir haben auch
gute Erfolge hier verzeichnet und das
ist auch das Verdienst der SPD das
feiert man heute Abend und jetzt muss
man gucken mit wem man in die Koalition
geht
genau das wird die spannende Frage
vielen Dank Christina für die ersten
Eindrücke die CDU mit leichten Verlusten
gut zwei im Moment Prozentpunkte
24,5 ja man hätte sich sicherlich
gewünscht auch wieder die Nase vorn zu
haben das hat jetzt nicht geklappt reif
nein und das ist schon eindeutig die CDU
in Bremen ist Kummer gewohnt und dieser
Tag reiht sich da auch wieder ein und
als vorhin die Zahlen kamen wir sehen
jetzt gleich die Bilder da war dann
schon auch klar das ist Enttäuschung und
das hatte man sich anders vorgestellt
als der Balken der SPD hochging war das
Zähneknirschen noch lauter als dann aber
das relativ schlechte Ergebnis der
Grünen zu sehen und zu hören war da
brauchst du so etwas wie Applaus auf die
wir jetzt hier hören das war also
sozusagen nur noch der Galgen Humor
andere hat es noch schwer noch schärfer
getroffen das war sozusagen das einzige
Momentum hier auf Seiten der CDU was für
einen gelungenen Abend spricht ansonsten
ist jetzt hier erstmal die Stimmung
nicht mehr so toll es geht jetzt darum
zu überlegen was kann man machen kann
man sich als Junior Partner der SPD
anbieten das wäre eine Möglichkeit die
Grünen hatten nach der letzten Wahl als
die CDU stärkste Kraft war den Preis
ziemlich hoch getrieben für eine
Koalition mit der SPD das könnte also
gut sein wenn die CDU jetzt als
möglicher Koalitionspartner mitspielt
dass die Reise fallen das wird also ein
Erkenntnis des heutigen Abends sein
Dankeschön Ralf ja und da können wir
Matjes schon von weitergeben denn wir
haben ein Gesprächspartner aus
bundespolitischer Sicht ich begrüße
herzlich in Berlin Carsten Linnemann
stellvertretender CDU Bundesvorsitzender
schönen guten Abend ja also die CDU
verliert ein bisschen vor allem kann sie
die Position als stärkste Kraft nicht
behaupten wir enttäuscht sind sie und
warum ist das so
25 Prozent in einer Großstadt als CDU
das ist schon ein gutes Ergebnis aber
sie haben Recht Frau Schausten die CDU
wollte die Wahl gewinnen das ist
offenkundig nicht passiert und deswegen
Glückwunsch an Herrn bogenschulte seine
Person hat herausragende
glaubwürdigkeitswerte und er hat in
seiner Person diese Wahl gewonnen und
deswegen Glückwunsch aus Berlin es würde
nach dieser Prognose jetzt reichen für
eine Fortsetzung der Rot-Grün roten
Regierung sie gratulieren Herrn
bogenschulte raten sie ihren Bremer
Landesverband gleichwohl jetzt sich als
Juniorpartner zur Verfügung zu stellen
für eine große Koalition denn die CDU
will ja etwas verändern in Bremen
ich rate gar nichts ich habe immer damit
Probleme gehabt wenn andere die nichts
mit dem Bundesland zu tun haben von oben
gesagt haben wie man sich zu benehmen
hat oder mit wem man koalieren muss das
muss die Bremer CDU entscheiden wie Sie
mit dem Ergebnis umgeht aber eins ist
klar
so wie es in Bremen aussieht ich war
auch dort im Wahlkampf im
Bildungsbereich letzter Verschuldung pro
Kopf letzter Sicherheit Schlusslicht bei
den ganz herausragenden Punkten selbst
bei der Arbeitslosigkeit ganz unten im
Tabellenkeller also ich finde so kann
man nicht weitermachen mit so einer
Konstellation natürlich muss dass der
bodenschulter im entscheiden aber ich
finde es braucht einen Neustart für
Bremen und dieser Verantwortung sollte
er nachkommen
dann höre ich da doch so ein Gewissen
Rat durch ähm Herr Lehne Mann
oft aus diesem prognoseergebnis ist es
im Moment noch auch für den Bund
stellen sie fest dass der
Bundesvorsitzende Friedrich Merz
offenbar nun auch nicht automatisch so
etwas wie ein März Faktor entfaltet
nein das ist ja ein ziemlich kleines
Bundesland aber natürlich was mich
besorgt ist das ist auf anhiebten
zweistelligen
dass die die Protestpartei BÜRGER IN WUT
sofort auf den zweistelligen Punkt
kommen
Ergebnis kommen das finde ich
bedenkenswert für die etablierten
Parteien da müssen wir höllisch
aufpassen deswegen ist es zentral für
die CDU dass wir jetzt in neuen
programmprozess uns klarer als in der
Vergangenheit zu den Themen äußern und
zwar zu allen Themen keine außen vor
lassen ich glaube die Menschen haben
eine Sehnsucht nach Clara Sprache auch
von etablierten groß großen
Volksparteien und dieser Verantwortung
müssen wir gerecht werden sarkas
Lindemann der stellvertretende
Bundesvorsitzende herzlichen Dank nach
Berlin
so und wir können gleich weitergehen zur
SPD und zu Kevin kühner dem
Generalsekretär der kühn hat die letzte
Wahl auf Landesebene beim februar in
Berlin da haben wir auch gesprochen und
sie hatten einen schlechten Abend weil
die SPD den Spitzenplatz abgeben musste
jetzt hier in Bremen hat sie den heute
abend zurückerobert wie dankbar sind Sie
Andreas
ja so wie ich ihn nach der Berlinwahl
ehrlich geantwortet habe mache ich das
auch heute wir sind sehr froh über
dieses Wahlergebnis und ich war viel im
Wahlkampf vor Ort ich glaube es ist auch
ein gerechtfertigtes Wahlergebnis man
hat wirklich in vielen Gesprächen merken
können das ganz viele Menschen in Bremen
und Bremerhaven ein großes Vertrauen in
Andreas bovenschulte und eben in die SPD
im Land Bremen haben die einfach nah an
den Themen dort sind an der Stärkung des
Industriestandortes im sozialen
ausgleichbild Bremen ist kein Reiches
Bundesland und will natürlich trotzdem
auch Klimaziele und anderes mehr
schaffen und da ist die SPD einfach in
Bremen und Bremerhaven am Puls gewesen
und ja die Beliebtheitswerte von Andreas
Bovenden sind sicherlich nicht schädlich
für diesen Wahlabend gewesen rot grün
rot in Bremen r2g wie man dies Bündnis
gerne nennt ist ja nach dem Aussehen
Berlin jetzt nur noch in Bremen eine
Option das ist es aber weiterhin sie
werden auch keine Empfehlungen
aussprechen aber erwarten sie dass es so
Fortsetzung kommt
na wenn ich mir das Ergebnis oder dass
wir es sich abzeichnet anschaue dann
darf man ja erstmal festhalten wir haben
satt zugewonnen wir sind stärkste Kraft
und gegen die SPD kann in Bremen keine
Regierung gebildet werden es sind
unterschiedliche Mehrheiten möglich und
es ist jetzt wie immer bei
Landtagswahlen bei unseren
Parteifreunden vor Ort zu entscheiden
wie sie verhandeln um das Beste aus
unserem Programm rauszuholen da werden
wir keine Ratschläge hier aus dem
Willy-Brandt-Haus geben sondern das
wissen die vor Ort am besten wie sie
sich da verhalten werden
noch mal einen Moment auf die
Koalitionspartner im Bund wie die in
Bremen hier abgeschnitten haben Grünen
mit deutlichen Verlusten offenbar FDP
noch nicht klar ob sie es in die
Bürgerschaft wirklich schaffen wird
vielleicht mit einem Sitz über
Bremerhaven was sagt Ihnen das für als
Botschaft auch für die ampelregierung im
Bund
ich glaube da sollte man jetzt nicht zu
viel rein Geheimnissen an diesem
Wahlabend es ist einfach so sind
schwierige Zeiten im Bundesregierung
muss es andauernd Entscheidung von
großer Tragweite treffend sind viele
auch verteilungspolitische Fragen die
öffentlich diskutiert werden die ganze
sensibel sind und wir freuen uns da
bitte ich um Verständnis da gucken wir
ganz auf uns selbst wir freuen uns
einfach dass eben in einem Bundesland
was nicht zu den aller reichsten gehört
dass wir dort heute einen klaren
politischen Auftrag bekommen haben das
ist in Zeiten in denen über die
Bezahlbarkeit von wandelprozessen
Stichwort Heizung und anderes gesprochen
wird ein wichtiger Hinweis für uns in
der Sozialdemokratie dass wir mit
unserem Ausgleich zwischen Klimazielen
und der Bezahlbarkeit des Alltags das
wird auf einen guten Pfad sind und dafür
steht eben auch Andreas Bovenden so
gesehen kann Olaf Scholz von Andreas
bovenschulte noch was lernen
ich glaube er muss jetzt nichts lernen
von ihm aber wir freuen uns einfach
Ihnen unseren Reihen zu haben und es ist
ja auch ganz wichtig weiteres starkes
sozialdemokratisch regiert das Land im
Bundesrat hinter uns zu haben
fortschrittspolitik der Ampel in Berlin
setzt eben auch einen Rückhalt in den
Ländern voraus da ist Andreas
bovenschulte ganz wichtiger zum Beispiel
rund um das Thema übergewinn Steuern für
Unternehmen im letzten Jahr eine
wichtige Debatte angestoßen und die auch
ins Ziel bringen können und insofern ist
ja ein Impulsgeber für die ganze
Sozialdemokratie und ich hoffe mir
weitere Impulse dieser Art von ihm wir
brauchen sowas Kevin kühner der
spd-generalsekretär vielen Dank nach
Berlin
so jetzt haben wir hier ins Land Bremen
die Linke hat endlich abgeschnitten wie
beim letzten Mal 11% und das ist schon
eine Nachricht denn die Linke war bei
den letzten Landtagswahlen wirklich
immer mit Verlusten
unterwegs so deshalb ist interessant die
Stimme der Linken Wirtschaftssenatorin
hier in Berlin zu hören bei Ihringen
ja Bettina neben mir steht nun die
Spitzenkandidatin der Linkspartei
Christina Vogt Frau Vogt der Jubel war
eben groß wie bewerten Sie die ersten
Zahlen setzen Sie nun auf eine
Fortsetzung von Rot-Grün rot wir sind
natürlich wahnsinnig froh wir haben
immer wieder gespiegelt bekommen dass
wir einen tollen Job in der Regierung
gemacht haben haben aber natürlich nicht
den Rückendeckung so aus der
Bundespartei gehabt die wir Ihnen gerne
gehabt hätten und haben auch ein
bisschen darunter gelitten dass die
Grünen in der Regierung sehr umstritten
waren insofern freuen wir uns wahnsinnig
über das Ergebnis ist muss man sagen es
ist ja nur eine Prognose und hoffen dass
wir unsere Arbeit in dieser Regierung
weiter fortsetzen können vielen Dank
Frau Vogt und damit zurück zu dir ins
waldstudio Bettina ja herzlichen Dank
und jetzt höre ich ist der
CDU-Spitzenkandidat Frank Imhoff schon
vor seiner Anhänger getreten da rein
dann die Musik aus hallo Leute wir
wollen reden
[Applaus]
waren wir vor so eine Kulisse zu stehen
stehen zu dürfen und ich muss ehrlich
sagen ich bin ein Stück weit stolz ich
sage immer warum ich das bin ich möchte
nämlich erstmal danken ich möchte euch
danken weil ich so stolz auf euch bin
auf unsere Partei bin ey ihr habt so
einen tollen Wahlkampf gemacht ihr habt
so dermaßen den Wahlkampf gerockt an
jeder Ecke habe ich euch gesehen es war
egal ob es am Sonntag war alles am
Samstag Nachmittag waren nach Feierabend
vor der Arbeit nach der Arbeit egal ich
habe euch alle auf die Straßen gesehen
die haben alle zusammen mit mir und mit
Wiebke zusammen gelaufen und die hat
fast alles gegeben hier für uns und
unser Bundesland und deswegen ein ganz
ganz fettes Dankeschön an euch die
Videos toll danke schön
[Applaus]
und der zweite danke schön was ich hier
wirklich loswerden muss ist wirklich
auch an die Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeiter aus dem CDU Haus das muss
man wirklich sagen die haben wirklich
viel viel geleistet die Tage und unter
anderem auch ja
unter anderem ein bisschen vergessen
Claudia Grabowski Dirk Hoffmann Tobias
Henze natürlich und wo es hin ja wo sind
ja Finja wegen einmal Finja habe ich
überall begleitet das war mein Schatten
hey ganz ganz klasse ein Rieser und für
alle anderen haben
[Applaus]
das gehört auch zur wahlabenden dazu der
Dank natürlich an die Wahlkämpferinnen
und Wahlkämpfer Frank immer vor dass der
CDU-Spitzenkandidat der offenkundig den
zweiten Platz ganz gut verkraftet ähm
jedenfalls ist ja guten Mutes das war
interessant zu sehen und wir hören jetzt
das auch der Wahl Sieger des Abends
Andreas bovenschulte schon rausgekommen
ist und zu sein Anhängerinnen und
Anhänger ansprechen
[Applaus]
liebe Genossen und genossen was für ein
Tag was für ein Ergebnis wir haben ein
harten Wahlkampf gemeinsam gefochten und
es hat sich gelohnt die SPD in Bremen
zurück die Nummer eins in Bremen das
sind wir
[Applaus]
und ich will möchte mich natürlich bei
all denjenigen bedanken die uns heute
mit ihrer Stimme unterstützt haben und
die dieses grandiose Ergebnis möglich
gemacht haben wenn es nicht so viele
Bürgerinnen und Bürger geben würde die
sagen würden die Politik der SPD die ist
gut für Bremen und Bremerhaven weil wir
für starke Wirtschaft und gute Arbeit
stehen weil wir für ein Gemeinwesen
stehen das sozialzusammenhalt weil wir
das ganze Land und alle Menschen im
Blick haben und nicht irgendwelche
partikular Interessen in den Mittelpunkt
stehen deshalb freut es mich so sehr
dass uns so viele Menschen heute mit
ihrer Stimme unterstützt haben und ich
sage all diesen ganz ganz herzlichen
Dank
ja der Wahl Gewinner Andreas
bovenschulte der SPD-Bürgermeister der
jetzt die Wahl hat weiter mit Grünen und
Linken oder große Koalition vor vier
Jahren waren ist die Grünen die ihm in
den insamt halfen jetzt schauen wir noch
mal schnell zu den Grünen die ja auf mit
Verlusten rechnen müssen gemäß der
Prognose rund 5% gings bergab ja Linda
das hat schlechte Stimmung gemacht
ja diese Zahlen sind wirklich ein
herberschlag für die Grünen sie bleiben
damit wirklich weit unter ihren eigenen
Erwartungen zurück und es hat wirklich
viele hier mitgenommen das sah man auch
an den Reaktionen hier kurz nach 18 Uhr
da gab es versteinerte Minen kaum
Applaus und das Gefühlt Minuten lang und
den ersten Applaus den gab es eigentlich
erst als sie auf dem Bildschirm die
Sitzverteilung gezeigt wurde und das
zeigt einmal mehr die Hoffnung der
Grünen die ihn heute Abend noch bleibt
nämlich das Andreas bogenschulter auf
ein weiter so nach der Wahl setzt
Dankeschön Linda für die Eindrücke und
das können wir jetzt vertiefen mit und
mit nuripur dem grünen
Bundesvorsitzenden den ich hier bei mir
im Studio begrüße ja nur die Grünen
verlieren deutlich und ehrlich gesagt
auch erstmals seit Jahren wenn man so
auf die landtagswahlergebnisse der
letzten Jahren guckt indem sie sehr
erfolgsgewöhnt waren was ist ihre
Erklärung
wir haben als erstes natürlich Andreas
bogenschulte zu gratulieren da heißt
heute der Wahl Gewinner wenn die
Ergebnisse so bleiben es ist ein
enttäuschendes Ergebnis für uns kein
schöner Abend und äh wir haben sicher
auch kein Rückenwind gegeben von der
Bundesebene aus es gab sicher auch
Gründe hier in Bremen und die werden wir
zusammen die nächsten Tage analysieren
sie haben gesagt kein Rückenwind aus
Berlin ist das so gesehen auch eine
Quittung für Robert habe nein es ist
eindeutig dass der Bundestrend gerade
nicht jetzt immer weiter steigt bei uns
wir sind von den ampelparteien die eine
die immer noch deutlich über dem
Wahlergebnis 2021 ist und dennoch ist es
der Trend jetzt nicht zwingend so dass
man jetzt euphorisiert ist und
dementsprechend ist der Sockel klar dass
er niedriger ist als bei den letzten
Landtagswahlen gleichzeitig ist Bremen
eigentlich immer über dem Bundestrend
gewesen das ist diesmal nicht der Fall
und das werden wir zusammen anschauen
zeigt sich da womöglich ein Muster wenn
sie sagen sie wollen das jetzt
analysieren das nämlich der Eindruck
entsteht dass die grünen Politik machen
nicht mit den Bürgerinnen und Bürger
sondern eher gegen die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger die Spitzenkandidatin hier hat ja
auch berichtet dass sie im Wahltag immer
auf das heizungsgesetz angesprochen
worden ist es ist notwendig einfach sich
anzuschauen warum dieses Land nicht
krisenfest ist und es ist nicht
Riesenfest weil ganz viele
Entscheidungen nicht getroffen worden
sind und dementsprechend muss man
natürlich auch Dinge ändern in diesem
Land wir müssen schauen was wir falsch
gemacht haben es ist in erster Linie
auch ein Tag von Demut für uns Grüne und
wir müssen uns anschauen was wir besser
machen können aber was keine Option ist
ist dass wir uns nur noch von Umfragen
leiten lassen
schon sagen jetzt wenn wir keine
Entscheidung mehr treffen keine
Änderungen mehr
anschieben dafür sind die
Herausforderungen auch zu groß vor dem
diesem Land steht jetzt sind aber keine
Umfragen sondern natürlich
Wahlergebnisse also tatsächlich auch
eine Reaktion und ein Votum der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger
haben sie einkalkuliert dass der die
Höhenflüge der Grünen vorbei sind es ist
mehr selbstverständlich dass es auch
Rücken das ist auch Rückschläge gibt und
dass wir gerade in der Regierungszeit wo
man sehr viele Entscheidungen trifft die
nicht alle populär sein müssen aber wo
man natürlich schauen muss dass man die
Leute auch mitnimmt dass man da jetzt
nicht immer nur Herzen einsammelt das
ist klar und das wusste mal vorher wenn
ich jetzt für die Bundesebene das sagen
darf wir sind eigentlich gut im soll es
ist dringend notwendig dass wir
natürlich immer wieder auch nach Steuern
und unsere Leute in Bremen haben sich
wirklich reingeschmissen die haben echt
ein super Wahlkampf gemacht und wir
werden uns nachher und später
miteinander zusammensetzen und überlegen
woran ist
medienanspruch erheben hier weiter mit
regieren zu wollen als große Verlierer
des Abends die Entscheidung liegt beim
Wahlgewinner das ist Andreas
bovenschulte und die Sozialdemokratie
wir sind bereit bei den Verantwortung zu
übernehmen weil wir glauben dass das
Bremen und Bremerhaven gut tut und weil
wir ja sehen dass große Koalition in
erster Linie in so einem Voda Modus von
nicht Entscheidungen immer wieder sofort
verfallen und da Auftakt der letzten
großen Koalition in Berlin war jetzt
nicht unbedingt eine Einladung dass man
findet dass das was gut ist und vielen
Dank der Grünen Bundesvorsitzende hier
für den Besuch im Studium danke schön so
und wir schauen jetzt noch mal auf die
Bürger in Wut eine Vereinigung hier in
Bremen und Bremerhaven die AFD war nicht
angetreten weil sie keine ordentlichen
Wahllisten eingereicht hatten und jetzt
konnten die Bürger in Wut ganz
offensichtlich da auch Protestpotenzial
abschöpfen Matthias damals interessante
so sieht das aus die Bürger in Wut haben
die höchsten Zugewinne so sieht's im
Moment aus woran liegt das die
Forschungsgruppe dann etwa 120
Wahllokalen in Bremen und Bremerhaven
Interviews geführt und aus den Daten die
so gewonnen wurden kann man folgendes
sagen von denen die heute die Bürger in
Wut gewählt haben haben vor vier Jahren
noch 16 Prozent CDU gewählt in absoluten
Zahlen sind das etwa 4.000 Wählerinnen
und Wähler und der dickste
brockenerwartungsgemäß wer heute BIW
gewählt hat hat vor vier Jahren AFD
gewählt 32 Prozent oder etwa 9000
stimmen so viel dazu
schon interessant vielen Dank Matthias
denn die CDU hätte natürlich nachdem die
AFD nicht antreibt eigentlich den
Versuch unternehmen müssen hier mehr
abzuschöpfen was jetzt zu den Bürgern in
Wut gegangen ist auch zur FDP hätten
natürlich manche gehen können wir
schauen jetzt noch mal auf die FDP die
zittern muss ob sie tatsächlich hier
über die 5% Hürde kommt ich höre gerade
dass dort der
Gesprächspartner bei der FDP noch nicht
bereit steht deshalb vertiefen wir das
jetzt mal bei der BIW den Bürgern in Wut
und kein Niklas hat den
Spitzenkandidaten getroffen
von der Wählervereinigung BÜRGER IN WUT
10,5 Prozent wie erklären Sie sich den
Wahlerfolg nun der ist einerseits zu
erklären weil wir jahrelang gute Arbeit
in der Stadtverordnetenversammlung und
in der Bürgerschaft gemacht haben die
Menschen wissen also wenn sie BÜRGER IN
WUT wählen was sie dann bekommen und
dann ist natürlich eine hohe
Unzufriedenheit hier in dieser Stadt zu
spüren Stichwort Kriminalitätsbekämpfung
die nicht richtig läuft Stichwort
Schulbildung wir sind am auf dem letzten
Platz hier bei der bei den ganzen Pisa
Studien und das schlägt sich im
Wahlergebnis natürlich wieder haben sie
auch davon profitiert dass die AFD hier
nicht zugelassen wurde also genaue
Zahlen haben wir nicht aber 50% der
Wähler die wir offenbar für uns gewinnen
konnten haben vorher nicht AFD gewählt
und es wird der heute Abend spannend
sein woher diese Wähler kommen ob sie
von der CDU kommt von der SPD ich glaube
dass sehr viele von der CDU kommen die
mit dem links kostet der CDU eben nicht
mehr einverstanden waren waren sie
Sammelbecken für Protest Wähler
wir waren Sammelbecken für unzufriedene
das ist richtig ob das nun alles
Protestwähler sind das ist da kann man
ja auch noch mal unterscheiden aber
grundsätzlich sind wir sind wir eine
konservative Wählervereinigung und ich
glaube wir haben ganz viele Konservative
für uns gewinnen können die eben nicht
mehr mit der CDU zufrieden waren das war
Jan Timke von der Wählervereinigung
Bürger ein gut schönen Dank danke
Dankeschön keine Klage ja wir sehen
Bremen ist etwas Besonderes das kleinste
deutsche Bundesland mit Bremerhaven ein
zwei städte-staat und eines dass sich
ein anspruchsvolles Wahlverfahren
gegeben hat ist da vier kumuliert und
panaschiert werden deshalb dauert es mit
der Auszahlung übrigens vorerst hat die
Prognose der Forschungsgruppe Wahlen
Geltung die zum Glück ja immer sehr
exakt ist deshalb schauen wir jetzt mal
ausführlicher ausführlicher auf Bremen
und seine Menschen auf ihr Lebensgefühl
und ihre Erwartungen Bremen ist ein Land
der Gegensätze und so heißt die nun
folgende Reportage auch zwischen Hafen
Harz und Hanse schauen wir mal
[Applaus]
spielt ihre Musik in Bremen oder
andersrum
sie möchte von hier zu den Sternen
er aus Bremerhaven nicht weg
seine Immobilien sollen die Hansestadt
prägen
und er packt lieber an als große Sprüche
zu klopfen
[Musik]
Schichtbeginn für Dennis Kastens in
Bremer schwerguthafen er ist gleich als
Kranführer eingeplant
die flachen Dinger
wir hängen das Geschirr ein da kommt
jetzt noch das Teil zwischen dann
nochmal vier Schlingen nach unten und
dann wird ein walzenständer entladen
großes schweres Laches Ding für
irgendeine Firma
Dennis Kastens ist einer von 500
Beschäftigten hier früher waren es
dreimal so viele das war vor seiner Zeit
seit 8 Jahren arbeitet ihr im Hafen wenn
du hast genug getan heute
erzählt halt ob du was kannst oder nicht
so wichtig ist was drumherum ist wie du
aussiehst was du sonst so machst
dieses Ziel deine Arbeitsleistung und
danach versuchen
Dennis Kastens hat sich hochgearbeitet
vom lagerlogistiker zum Schichtleiter
der 30-Jährige kann so gut wie jede
Maschine im Hafen bedienen
[Musik]
bin hier eigentlich irgendwie so
reingeraten mittlerweile würde ich nicht
mehr tauschen wollen fällt mir gut
gerade das Arbeitsklima
ja also
unerhaufter Traumjob sozusagen
so jetzt ist zum Beispiel der Punkt die
müssen da unten erst noch vorbereiten
bis ich tiefer kommen kann und das Ding
anhängen kann jetzt kann ich die
Aussicht genießen nicht der schlechteste
Job ne
er weiß auch wie es ist unten mit
anzupacken am Wochenende oder in der
Nacht
gearbeitet wird
so Wind und Wetter immer draußen viel
schwerere Gerätschaft und schweres
schweres Geschirr schwere Ladung das
interessante am Stück gut man sieht was
am Haken ist alles mögliche schon dabei
gewesen und regelmäßig sogar Teile für
die Ariane Rakete die werden immer
hinten die werden da so ein Schwimmbad
an der Rampe runter und wird dann von
hinten beladen da wird reingefahren das
sind Teile für die Raumfahrer ne das ist
schon nicht alltäglich
[Musik]
Bremen nicht nur Hafenstadt sondern auch
city of Science Wissenschaftsstandort
[Musik]
Raumfahrt Unternehmen produzieren hier
mitten in der Stadt also wenn ich hier
reingehe
dann nehme ich also wenn man denkt ist
das am Ende so hochkommt mit der Rakete
und allem und dann da oben tatsächlich
fliegt
also ich finde es einfach beeindruckend
diese Halle ist ein Reinraum höchste
hygienestufe hier werden
Wettersatelliten gebaut preis pro Stück
250 Millionen Euro Emma Maurer macht mit
gut 30 anderen ein duales Studium im
Unternehmen wenn sie nicht in der
Hochschule ist lernt sie hier bevor wir
wirklich an den Satelliten dürfen müsst
ihr ein gewisses steckertraining
absolvieren weil wir haben hier einfach
Stecker die haben 104 kleine Pins die
sehr sehr schnell vorbeugen werden
können kaputt gehen wisst ihr noch
worauf man alles achten muss
am Kabel ziehen sondern vom Stecker und
nicht rütteln
ja ich kann sonst anfangen aber ein
verbogener PIN kann richtig teuer werden
kein Wunder dass sie erster Modell
trainieren müssen Emma Maurer macht das
gerne seit der Oberstufe interessiert
sich die 21-Jährige für Raumfahrt
das hat schon mal gut geklappt also ich
komme ja aus der Nähe von Bremen
deswegen waren wir Bremen
und die Auswahl an Arbeitgebern im
Bereich der Raumfahrt ist ja nur noch
nicht besonders groß
aber ich habe mich dann hier für OHB in
Bremen beworben also ich bin sehr
glücklich hier
Lehe in Bremerhaven gilt als Armenhaus
des Bundeslandes die Arbeitslosenquote
seit Jahren über 30%. wenig
Möglichkeiten für die Kinder deswegen
ist er einmal in der Woche für Sie da
ein Touch als ein Jack bietet hier
Boxtraining an
Jungs 15 Minuten
[Musik]
die Teilnahme kostet kein Geld sondern
vollen körperlichen Einsatz
alles hier bleibt ihr bleibt ihr bleibt
sehr sehr sehr sehr selten los los los
los los
hau hau hau raus du auch jetzt hier das
Angebot nennt sich hot Training erfunden
in Bremen für benachteiligte
Stadtviertel inzwischen gibt es das auch
in Berlin und München
los wir gehen runter 2 Stunden
Sozialarbeit mit Schweiß Herz und klaren
Ansagen
trainiert das ist was heftiges weil das
ist Kampfsport ich will euch versuchen
die Philosoph beizubringen was das
heißen Kampfsport zu sein wenn ich z.B
höre dass ich draußen niemals hier
klappt von meinen von meinen Jungs raus
das tolle ich nicht das will ich nicht
hat keine Ausbildung die Schule
abgebrochen aber das stört die Kids
nicht der zwölfjährige Abteil Rahim
kommt regelmäßig
der Streik uns zwar
an aber meint es ja nicht
lass deine Deckung nicht fallen okay
wieder zurück zum Kind nicht fallen
lassen
zack zack ja und weiter und beweg dich
mal ein bisschen hin und her kurz
Training soll Selbstvertrauen geben und
Disziplin
[Musik]
halt also nachher dann brauche ich es
se
[Musik]
wenn man Kampfsportler ist wird man
Rüger weil dann du hattest ein scheiß
Arbeitstag oder zum Beispiel zu oder
gehst du siehst deine Boxhandschuhe an
dann Haus und Samstag und Sonntag
wo habe ich ein Probleme also ich muss
weitermachen ich muss mich okay
Armes Bremen das Bundesland hat auch
Geld Unternehmer und Bauprojekte wie
dieses große Geschäftsgebäude vor sieben
Jahren geplant nun fast fertig
[Musik]
Marco Bremermann ist Immobilieninvestor
Familienunternehmen dritte Generation in
dieses Gebäude sollen Geschäfte und
Büros wir sind in einer der besten Lagen
fernsehstadt Bremen natürlich und das
ist einer der wenigen Neubauten der
Bremer Innenstadt hier 700.000
Quadratmeter die realisiert werden plus
zwei tiefblasen Geschosse und welche
Größenordnung ist das hier verglichen
mit den anderen das ist so das mittlere
Segment was wir bilden rund 2700
Immobilien besitzt Bremermann mit seinem
Unternehmen etwa jedes dritte Gebäude
hier am Wald Spitzenlage am Rand der
Bremer Altstadt das ist in die alte
Verteidigungsanlage der der Stadt Bremen
damals das ist ja noch ein bisschen
Konflikt beladen war mit dem
niedersächsischen Umland und dass ihr
die alten Wehranlagen sind zwar im 18
Jahrhundert eingeebnet worden durch das
richtig im Sinne aber hier ist quasi
früher die Verteidigungssituation von
Alt Bremen sichergestellt worden auf die
andere Seite zur kontoska Bewohnern die
die eindringliche gewartet haben um die
Stadttor Ben
Familie Freunde Arbeit das ist alles in
Bremerhaven seit sechs Monaten auch das
Hot Training weiter weiter weiter weiter
weiter weiter weiter weiter weiter
weiter weiter los
weiter Jungs kommt kämpft ihr sollt
kämpfen alles gegeben nun alles
aufräumen der 21-Jährige legt großen
Wert auf Ordnung früher war das anders
da hat er für Unordnung gesorgt und
Ärger besucht am
15.12.2020 wurde ich angestochen
Richtung Herz und Richtung weil
warum weil ich ja halt auch cool sein
wollte so mein mein wie soll ich das
sagen mein Manga helfen wollte und bei
der Stress hatte das hat mein Leben zum
Positiven verändert ich war auf Krücken
ich konnte nicht laufen nix ne und ich
war nicht mehr draußen unterwegs und das
und so ich war einfach nur zu Hause
das war richtig geil weil ich bin dann
halt von alles rausgekommen ich habe
dann angefangen zu lernen so
recherchieren und das und so mich selber
erkennen zu lernen dass er Boxen kann
wusste er Eid hat gehörte mit 14 zu den
besten in Deutschland nun weiß er sein
Talent zählt nicht nur im Ring
jetzt bin ich hier und dafür danke ich
auch Gott ehrlich weil es im Leben ist
nichts umsonst
seinen Unterhalt verdiente als
Leiharbeiter in der
Lebensmittelproduktion das Training
macht er ehrenamtlich noch
[Musik]
mit dem neuen Geschäftshaus will Marco
Bremermann ab dem Sommer richtig Geld
verdienen ein Großteil der Räume ist
bereits vermietet
der Investor ist zufrieden und gönnt
sich einen Blick von oben auf seiner
Heimatstadt
Bremen seine wunderschöne Stadt und ich
meine wenn man hier sieht und sich das
mal anschaut welche Stadt hat so eine
Silhouette vom Dom über die Bürgerschaft
ist Rathaus bis hin zum Fußballstadion
in der Stadt man prägt mit solchen
Gebäuden auch die Stadt das ist auch ein
gewisses Vermächtnis was man dann in
diese Generation hinein bringt
die nächste Generation dafür einen Blick
hat
Studentin Emma liebt seit gut einem Jahr
in Bremen sie hat noch einiges zu
entdecken ist aber mittlerweile
angekommen
es ist keine reine studierendenstadt wie
zum Beispiel Münster aber man merkt
schon dass auch recht viele junge Leute
hier unterwegs sind ja ich meine das ist
Norddeutschland wenn einem Leute hallo
sagen dann ist es moin
wenn überhaupt aber ansonsten fühle ich
mich hier wohl
ihr Hobby Rudern Vereine gibt es viele
entlang der Weser diesen hat sie
ausgewählt weil andere Studierende hier
sind
[Musik]
in dieser Gruppe sind alle wegen der
Raumfahrt nach Bremen gekommen studieren
Mechatronik oder Informatik über Job und
Studium sprechen Sie beim Sport selten
aber manchmal kommen sie nicht drumherum
genau
[Musik]
witzig okay
also zu meiner Zeit als ich angefangen
habe junkerwerk in München da sah die
Welt anders aus
mindestens einmal in der Woche trainiert
immer sie will mit ihrem Team im Sommer
auch das ein oder andere Rennen fahren
im ersten Moment ist man natürlich
konzentriert und gut bei der Sache
aber es gibt dann doch so Momente wo man
dann doch mal guckt und dass man sich
bewusst man ist auf der Weser und das
Wetter ist schön das fühlt sich gut an
Hafenarbeiter dennis ist auch zugezogen
ursprünglich konnte aus Delmenhorst seit
2015 ist Bremen seiner Heimat
dieses maritimer aus ne Fluss mitten
durch
so ist alles relativ zentral alles
schnell zu erreichen
das ist schon eine schöne stadtliche
eigentlich genieße ich so ein bisschen
die Ruhe weiß ich natürlich jetzt mit
der mit der Wohnung hier aber ich wollte
mal wieder ein bisschen zentraler wohnen
dass ich alles um die Ecke habe
für ihn ist es hier ganz schön ein
bisschen Grün und auch der Arbeit wegen
kurzer Arbeitsweg sparen wir da
ordentlich Zeit zur Zeit passt es ganz
gut hier nach dem Gassi Gang mit
Bulldogge Boris geht es noch mal zu den
Biergärten an der Bremer schlachte die
Gesellschaft seines Hundes reicht Dennis
der begeisterte Motorradfahrer verbringt
viel Zeit alleine
ich mache das auf ich finde das sehr
entspannt auf uns immer sehr laut mein
Alter ist sehr strukturiert
das ist immer so ein bisschen
durchgetaktet er genieße ich das sehr
einfach nur Kaffee zu sitzen
seine Zukunftspläne noch ein
kranführerschein und weitere Tattoos
vielleicht sogar im Gesicht ansonsten
bitte wenig Veränderung
ich bleibe in Bremen das steht für mich
fest er meint damit die Stadt nicht das
Bundesland rund 50 km entfernt dieser
abwärts ist ja noch Bremerhaven Heimat
von iTouch als hancak
Bremerhaven das ist hindorf
einfach klar und deutlich dass es hier
ein Dorf jeder kennt jeden nächste Woche
Bruder okay
ich finde es hier eigentlich chillig
weil ich bin da ich bin euch ehrlich bin
hier groß geworden ich könnte auch gar
nicht hier weg
fester Anlaufpunkt ist für ihn die
Islamische Gemeinde leer hier ist nicht
nur sein Gym hier betet er auch ich sag
nur so ich bin auch
los das Leben gegangen
quasi keinen Plan gehabt und so und
irgendwann habe ich den Weg gefunden
für ihn gehört zum Islam Toleranz
wenn jemand gut zu mir ist wenn ich noch
besser und unser Heiliger Professor
er hat gesagt
behandelt ein Menschen wie er als
Menschen ist nicht als Religion
ist einer von schätzungsweise 60.000
Muslimen im Land bringen diese Gemeinde
gehört zum islamischen Dachverband
bietet unterstützt von der staatlichen
Religionsbehörde in der Türkei
fünf mal am Tag bietet er wie es der
Islam vorschreibt eine feste Struktur
also wenn ich bete also wie gesagt das
gibt mir Hoffnung das gibt mir
Gleichgewicht auch im Leben das gibt mir
Zufriedenheit es gibt nur Freude
[Musik]
Immobilieninvestor Marco Bremermann auf
dem Weg in die Bremer Handelskammer der
Schütting wie das Gebäude heißt im 16
Jahrhundert von der Kaufmannschaft
gebaut dem Rathaus gegenüber bewusst als
Machtdemonstration die Botschaft Bremen
ist stark wegen des Handels
orisch betrachtet was für eine Größe
Bremen durch die Hanse mal gehabt hat
das darf man nicht vergessen es ging ja
hier im Norden Handelsbereich ohne
Bremen
das ist Vergangenheit der Einfluss der
Kaufleute auf die Stadt nicht auf eine
Tasse t ist Stefan Brockmann in den
Schütting gekommen Unternehmer und
vizepräses der Handelskammer der
persönliche Austausch ist wichtig so
macht man in Bremen Geschäfte schon
immer
ich kann heute noch tatsächlich mit ganz
ganz vielen Leuten Geschäfte per
Handschlag machen also
Herr Bremermann bei mir Kunde ist dann
kann man auch sagen so dass sitzen wir
per Handschlag um da brauche ich keinen
Vertrag für und dass dieses Vertrauen
das ist hier eine Kaufmannschaft noch
ein weiteren eben auch vorhanden das ist
für viele ist das Mehrwert als ein
schriftlicher Vertrag
Kaufleute und Schiffe das ist sowas wie
die ursprüngliche bremische DNA der
Neustädter Hafen erinnert mit seinem
Stück gut noch am ehesten an die
Vergangenheit Dennis Carstens hilft
heute bei der Verladung von Bauholz die
Ware soll nach Kanada und in die USA
gerade so Neustadt haben ist glaube ich
mit einer der letzten Wunder wirklich
viel passiert die meiste Ware wird seit
Jahren per Container in Bremerhaven
umgeschlagen Bremen ist für das schwer
gut Anlaufpunkt geblieben ob Container
oder Stückgut die Grundregeln sind für
alle Hafenarbeiter die gleichen auf gar
keinen Fall unserer schönen lassen
natürlich auf Hände Füße Kopf aufpassen
und nicht unachtsam werden wenn sich
Routine einschleicht wird meist
gefährlich
ich denke das ist hier schon was
besonderes und auch wichtig dass das am
Leben bleibt hier
Aushängeschild für Bremen
die Schüler werden Schalter fünf junge
Bremer eine Handvoll Songs und der Traum
von großen Bühnen
[Musik]
die Schüler Band auf den Weg ins
Abendprogramm zuerst was essen hoch im
Kurs Rollo eine Art gerollt hat Döner
[Musik]
der Roller
noch ein Bier und dann zum richtigen
Spot die silvallkreuzung in
bremerviertel
das ist meistens so der Startplatz man
trifft sich dann hier und dann geht man
von hier entweder los zu irgendwelchen
Häusern oder zu den jeweiligen Clubs
also wenn man irgendwie sagt das Eck im
Viertel weiß jeder dass wir
genau das hier meinen
das Viertel ist linksalternativ geprägt
hier treffen sich Künstler Pädagogen
Junkies und Studierende
das Viertel ist zwar schon identifiziert
aber es Viertel ist trotzdem noch
abgerannt oder runtergekommen und das
trifft Bremen als gleichzeitig Ernstes
Bundesland aber auch als Bundesland mit
den meisten Millionären und Millionären
prozentual fast dass das glaube ich ganz
gut zusammen hier
die meisten Millionäre sind es dann doch
nicht aber bei den Einkommensmillionären
liegt Bremen in der Spitzengruppe es
gibt schicke Willen auf ausladenden
Grundstücken
Einblicke in ihre Welt lassen reiche
Bremerinnen und Bremer aber höchst
ungern zu
grundsätzlich ist ja das prima auch dass
das soziale umgehen in Bremen immer sehr
überschaubar und sehr sehr bescheiden
dann kriegt er sehr man würde auch
geprägt auch von den Kindern als die
anderen davor speziell von den Eltern
Kindergärten Schulen und so weiter das
ist einfach ein Faden der zieht sich
durch den gesamtes Leben irgendwo auch
durch diese Bescheidenheit man kriegt
sie auch häufiger vermittelt es gibt in
Bremen eine relativ intensive Szene an
mieten das heißt dass die Bremer feiern
lieber zu Hause als dass das in der
Öffentlichkeit gemacht
wer nicht viel hat muss auch nichts
verbergen das Viertel ist sowas wie der
Gegenpol zur feinen Bremer Gesellschaft
mit meiner Familie vor zehn Jahren
hergezogen und ich komme eigentlich aus
Flensburg es war ja immer schon so sehr
schlechteste Beruf als ernstes
Bundesland und irgendwie schlechtes
Bildungssystem aber also Bremen ist die
längste Zeit wo ich jemals irgendwo
gelebt habe und ich fühle mich einfach
so zu Hause es gibt so ein Sprichwort
wem ist das größte Dorf Deutschlands und
das trifft auch ganz gut also Bremen ist
schon technisch gesehen groß aber es
fühlt sich kleiner an also ich würde
sagen es ist so Segen und Fluch zugleich
das Bremen halt schon echt also dann
doch schon noch kleiner ist als man
denkt und gerade in den in den jetzt
hier sag mal in unserem Bubble kennt man
halt einfach jeden
die Bierflaschen sind leer Zeit weiter
zu ziehen der Abend ist ja noch jung
[Musik]
13 Jahre und mehr haben sie jetzt in
Bremer Bildungswesen verbracht die drei
Freunde lernen für die Abi-Prüfung
Mathematik Kurven Diskussion
da bin ich schon in der zweiten Klasse
ausgestiegen also Mathe sagen wir so
Mathe war für mich der Grund weswegen
ich die zweite Klasse wiederholen musste
Bremens Schülerinnen und Schüler sind
bei bundesweiten Vergleichstests meist
die schlechtesten das ist doch den
dreien bekannt lässt sie aber kalt
ich habe jetzt drei Schulen besucht in
meinem Leben das ist allein in Bremen
ist es nur ein kleiner Teil und ich
meine bundesweit noch sehr viel
kleinerer Teil deshalb
weiß ich nicht inwiefern ich da jetzt
ein Vergleich ziehen kann ja das ist mir
eigentlich ziemlich egal ob jetzt in
einem anderen Bundesland das heißt dass
es schwieriger ist so weil im Endeffekt
ist es ein Abitur habe ich jetzt recht
einfach sehr gut okay wer hat sich
diesen Scheiß ausgegangen
zum Satelliten bauen beim Raumfahrt
Unternehmen OHB arbeiten mehr als 1200
Menschen die meisten können Matte also
das ist sowas mit Mathe und Technik
machen will das war mir schon recht früh
klar Raumfahrt das ist noch mal
besondere also es geht über das
alltäglich hinaus
die Branche sucht Fachkräfte emma hat
gute Chancen in Bremen zu arbeiten wenn
sie das will
schon gerne Ingenieurin in diesem
Bereich werden also ich finde es super
faszinierend und super spannend und
natürlich wenn man irgendwo mitarbeiten
würde und dann fliegt es wirklich hoch
und es klappt alles ich glaube es gilt
für uns alle dass das ein ziemlich coole
Sache wäre also
ja
also wenn ich könnte wenn es ganz
einfach wäre wie es sofort machen
aber momentan ist es ja noch sehr
schwierig und sehr teuer aber wenn wir
anbieten würde ich bin dabei
[Musik]
auf der deichpromenade in Bremerhaven
bei gutem Wetter ist es hier voller
Touristen jetzt ist er mit seinem
Gedanken alleine und die sind meist beim
holztraining das ist unbezahlbar da ist
mir das ganz egal das unbezahlbar so ein
Gefühl ehrlich Leute so ein Gefühl aber
ich bewirken was bei den Jungen also ich
bin ja selber noch jung wie du sagst ne
aber weil ich ja in deren Alter auch
viele Sachen schon falsch gemacht habe
wenn ich den das nicht so muten dass sie
das nicht versuchen müssen das auch
anders geht
und ich weiß auch dass wir Menschen wie
so eine Pflanze sind die auch wachsen
müssen und ich will weiter wachsen
es ist in Bremerhaven möglich
ja klar sieht ihr doch ich habe es ja
hier geschafft dass ich hier
rücktraininggleite ne ist alles möglich
ist alles möglich
fünf Perspektiven
zwei Städte
ein Bundesland
[Musik]
das ZDF in Bremen bei den Menschen ihren
Wünschen und Hoffnungen und jetzt wieder
bei den Wahlergebnissen und da gucken
wir uns den Stand der Dinge an Matthias
was machen wir gerne und hier haben die
Wählerinnen und Wähler in Bremen ja fünf
Stimmen zu verteilen jeweils auf
Parteien und Personen entsprechend
langwierig das Auszählen wir schauen mal
auf die Prognose da sehen wir die CDU
bei
24,5%, die SPD deutlich stärkste Partei
30%, die Grünen zwölf Prozent die Linken
11 % FDP 5% noch knapp und unsicher ob
sie in Bremen und Bremerhaven drin sein
wird und die Bürger in Wut mit
10,5%, dass der Stand im Moment ja
vielen Dank Matthias Fornoff so weit
also die unveränderte Lage in Bremen wir
wollen jetzt noch einmal zur Wahl in die
Türkei schauen und zu unserem
Korrespondenten ja Samen in ankaram ja
was lässt sich jetzt inzwischen ja knapp
drei Stunden nach Schließung der
Wahllokale zum Wahlausgang sagen haben
sich Trends verfestigt
also das ist wirklich sehr schwierig
hier in der Türkei zu sagen ich will
einfach nur mal unsere Quellen hier
nennen wir haben im Moment drei Quellen
das eine ist die staatliche
Nachrichtenagentur an der Dolo die von
der Wahlbehörde gespeist wird die meldet
im Moment nach Auszählung von ungefähr
36 % der Stimmen das Präsident Erdogan
klar mit 13% Infront liegt dann gibt es
eine andere Agentur die der
Opposition da steht die Agentur Anker
die meldet
sind wir bei
[Musik]
Oma gemeldet
eine Wahl bezahlen
[Musik]
wir müssen abwarten bis auf die großen
Städte ausge
zählt dann kann sich das alles auch noch
mal ändern aber was man in diesem
Mann wird die Zahlen werden sich alle
noch mal verändern und die
Wahlbeteiligung das ist jetzt schon klar
die liegt bei über
90%, also noch mal hören
in der letzten
Präsident
von Deutschland auf jeden Fall nur
freuen
[Musik]
ja vielen Dank Jörg nach Ankara also ich
hoffe Sie haben ihn verstehen können da
wurde es gerade laut im Hintergrund aber
ich glaube es ist deutlich geworden wie
volatil im Moment noch die Situation ist
das bleibt ein spannender Abend in der
Türkei vom Ausgang der Wahl hängt viel
ab für Europa deshalb berichtet heute
das schon als Hinweis auch dass heute
journal ausführlich aus Ankara mit
Christian sie was vor Ort jetzt sind wir
zurück in Bremen und wollen noch mal
nachholen was vorhin noch nicht geklappt
hat nämlich eine Stimme der FDP die hier
noch sich sorgen muss ob sie tatsächlich
die 5% Hürde nehmen kann und deshalb
wollen wir den Spitzenkandidaten hier im
Gespräch mit keine klar sehen
Tore Scheck der Spitzenkandidat der FDP
der Liberalen in diesem Wahlkampf die
FDP laut Prognosen knapp über der 5%
Hürde glauben Sie daran dass Sie den
Wiedereinzug schaffen im Moment ist nur
Prognosen dann muss man natürlich immer
vorsichtig sein wir warten auf die erste
Hochrechnung aber im Moment sieht sehr
danach aus dass wir unser Ziel wieder
auch in die Bürgerschaft einzuziehen
auch Teil der nächsten Bremischen
Bürgerschaft zu sein als FDP erreichen
werden und ja jetzt schauen wir mal
weiter aber es bleibt eine Zitterpartie
sie waren ja schon prognostiziert bei 6%
jetzt geht's wieder ein bisschen bergab
woran liegt
schauen wir mal das wird man dann im
Nachgang erarbeiten müssen wir standen
ja in vielen Umfragen vorher sehr stabil
auch bei über 6 Prozent
ob es das Kopf an Kopf Rennen war
zwischen den beiden großen Parteien oder
einfach grundsätzlich die politische
Situation in Bremen das wird man sehen
wir freuen uns auf jeden Fall an dieser
Stelle erstmal über das Vertrauen der
Wählerinnen und Wähler die uns ihre
Stimme gegeben haben und ja warten jetzt
die ersten Hochrechnungen ab
so der FDP-Spitzenkandidat also die FDP
muss noch zittern und jetzt ist im
Moment zu mir ins Studio gekommen der
Wahlsieger des heutigen Abends Andreas
bovenschulte SPD Bürgermeister von
Bremen der ist auch wird bleiben können
danke fürs kommen wir schauen jetzt mal
gerade interessante Analyse Daten an zum
Abschneiden ihrer Partei das wird sie
bestimmt interessieren Matthias
wenn ich auch eine Kamera habe da kommt
sie woher kommen die Wähler der SPD war
die Frage also schauen wir uns mal
genauer an von denen die heute die SPD
gewählt haben haben vor vier Jahren die
CDU gewählt 8 % in absoluten Zahlen etwa
6000 Wählerinnen und Wähler der größte
Brocken sind die die auch damals schon
die SPD gewählt haben und Grüne 13%
immerhin 10.000 Wählerinnen und Wähler
das heißt die SPD bleibt stark und
gewinnt dazu bei CDU und grün eine
interessante Grafik möchte ich Ihnen
noch zeigen da geht es um eine
Altersgruppe über 60 wo normalerweise
die CDU immer klar fahren ist hier in
Bremen ist es um erklärt die SPD weit
vorne und wir schauen mal wie sich das
entwickelt hat in den letzten vier
Jahren die CDU verliert in dieser
Altersgruppe Ü60 - 5 Punkte die SPD
gewinnt 5 Punkte hinzu und das ist ein
Teil der Erklärung sicher für den Erfolg
der Sozialdemokraten vielen Dank
Matthias so und der der für den Erfolg
verantwortlich ist steht jetzt bei uns
Andreas bovenschulte das war ja in den
letzten Wochen der bogenschulte
eigentlich schon ziemlich knappes Rennen
jedenfalls konnten sie nicht sicher sein
dass es so klappen würde wie erleichtert
sind sie heute abend also ich freue mich
über dieses hervorragende Ergebnis und
bin natürlich erleichtert es war in der
Tat ein Kopf an Kopf rennen und das
Schöne an der Demokratie ist die
Wählerinnen und Wähler entscheiden und
ich die Meinungsforschungsinstitute
insofern konnte niemand sicher sein wie
am Ende das Ergebnis ist deshalb freue
ich mich über dies grandiose Ergebnisse
für die Bremer SPD allerdings lagen die
Forschungsinstitute auch ziemlich gut
die haben sie nämlich tatsächlich schon
in Front gesehen jedenfalls in den
letzten 14 Tagen nun ging es hatten sie
diese historische Niederlage beim
letzten mal so ein bisschen in den
Knochen wahrscheinlich da ging es ja
acht Punkte runter 5 haben sie wieder
aufgeholt Wein das immer so bewusst im
Wahlkampf na klar also es wäre falsch zu
sagen dass die Niederlage beim letzten
Mal der SPD der Bremer SPD nicht in den
Knochen gesteckt hätte das war so
insofern haben wir ja auch gesagt wir
müssen richtig kämpfen und ich habe
meine Partei noch nie so
aktionsfreudig und so mobilisiert
gesehen wie in diesem Wahlkampf das war
ganz hervorragend also insofern muss man
sagen wir haben klaren Kurs gefahren wir
hatten eine sehr sehr engagierte Partei
und das war dann natürlich auch der
Schlüssel zum Erfolg nun sind Sie dank
des wetterweise zu uns schon etwas
früher gekommen weil wir sie natürlich
gleich in unserer 19 Uhr heute Sendung
hören wollen und die entscheidenden
Gretchen Fragen sparen wir uns noch mal
ein bisschen auf aber ich will schon mal
etwas Nachfragen beim letzten Mal haben
am Ende ja die Grünen ihnen in den
Sattel geholfen ohne die Grünen werden
sie nicht Bürgermeister wäre die SPD
nicht für und in der Regierung geworden
jetzt haben die sehr sehr stark verloren
ist da jetzt so auch ein bisschen
Genugtuung dabei dass am Ende sie sich
durchgesetzt haben nein überhaupt nicht
ich freue mich über gutes Ergebnis für
die SPD ich freue mich nicht über
schlechter Ergebnisse für andere
Parteien außer für rechtsradikale
Parteien und insofern ist die Situation
tatsächlich jetzt eine andere und damit
werden wir umgehen müssen ich habe immer
gesagt die jetzige Regierung hat eine
gute Arbeit gemacht das habe ich vor der
Wahl gesagt das finde ich immer noch wir
haben das Land gut durch die
verschiedenen Krisen gesteuert wir haben
auch immer gesagt wir gehen nicht mit
einer festen Koalitionsaussage in die
Wahl hat übrigens keine Partei in Bremen
gemacht und müssen dann hinterher gucken
wie sich die Dinge inhaltlich von dem
Gemeinsamkeiten ergeben aber das ist ein
bisschen Kaffeesatzleser rein und wir
müssen erstmal jetzt abwarten wie das
Endergebnis ist dann müssen morgen die
Gremien beraten und sich positionieren
dann geht es weiter lassen sie uns Herr
bodenschulte noch einen Blick auf dieses
Ergebnis der Bürger in Wut werfen und
ist die AFD konnte nicht antreten hatte
Formfehler produziert das wäre doch
eigentlich die große Chance gewesen
jetzt sozusagen diese diese
rechtspopulistischen Strömungen klein zu
halten zweistelliges Ergebnis so sieht
es aus für die Bürger in Wut wie sehr
besorgt sie das und was sagt Ihnen
dieses Ergebnis offenbar ist tatsächlich
doch viel Unzufriedenheit vorhanden in
diesem Land also das ist natürlich so
das gibt Anlass zu Sorge und das finde
ich überhaupt nicht gut zu Einordnung
muss man sagen das letzte Mal hatte die
AFD um die sechs Prozent BÜRGER IN WUT
2,4% wenn man das zusammenzählt waren
das 8,4% und wir haben ja weil nach weil
Befragung gehabt aus denen hervorgeht
dass viele ehemalige Wählerinnen und
Wähler der AFD jetzt bewege gewählt
haben weil die AFD nicht auf dem
Wahlzettel stand also so muss man
natürlich dieses zweistellige Ergebnis
einordnen und trotzdem
da gibt es Anlass zur Sorge und für mich
heißt das wir müssen der Frage starke
Wirtschaft gute Arbeit und soziale
Gerechtigkeit in den nächsten Jahren
noch mehr Schwerpunkt geben weil das ist
das glaube ich was die Menschen wollen
in schwierigen Situationen Klarheit
Sicherheit und eine vernünftige
Existenzgrundlage wir haben vorhin den
spd-generalsekretär also eine
bundesstimme gehört der jetzt Ihnen
natürlich gratuliert Kevin Kühnert und
gleichzeitig sagt er wünscht sich jetzt
mehr bodenschulte auf jeden Fall auch in
der Bundespolitik was kommt da auf sie
zu naja ich habe erstmal jetzt genug
damit zu tun in die Gespräche
einzutreten ab morgen und mich um die
Bremer und Bremerhaven Angelegenheiten
zu kümmern was richtig ist ich habe in
der Vergangenheit ob es um die
corona-pandemie ging oder über ein Thema
wie übergewinnsteuer auch deutlich
gemacht Bremen ist eins von 16
Bundesländern wir würden über den
Bundesrat an der Bundespolitik mit und
natürlich ist es auch die Aufgabe des
Bremer Bürgermeisters und Präsidenten
des Senats aus dieser
verfassungsrechtlichen Position raus
Bundespolitik mitzumachen sie bleiben
bei uns Schulter wir geben jetzt direkt
ab nach Mainz zur 19 Uhr heute Sendung
[Musik]
ein besonderer Tag heute für Deutschland
und die vom Krieg gezeichnete
ukraineski ist angereist in Berlin
Gesten enger Freundschaft und
gegenseitiger Dankbarkeit bei
Sicherheitsstufe 1 damit